I'm really thrilled to introduce to you
guys Gary there you go
Gary Vaynerchuk how many people here I
think he's a yes on this one have heard
of and follow Gary Vaynerchuk all right
this has been a really interesting
experience me because I've got a lot of
social love in bringing you on stage
which I really appreciate like the the
auxilary byproduct of having Gary Vee I
get a lot of follows it's great but you
may have noticed even though it looked
pretty dense about half the room isn't
really sure so first I'm gonna introduce
officially then we're gonna have him
tell you a little bit himself Gary
Vaynerchuk builds businesses fresh out
of college II took his family wine
business and grew it from a three
million dollar a year business to a
sixty million dollar a year business the
one that Aaron maybe we should check out
called Wine Library now he runs
vaynermedia one of the world's hottest
digital agencies along the way he's
become a prolific angel investor
adventure capitalist he's invested in
companies like Facebook Twitter Tumblr
goober Birchbox before eventually
co-founding vayner/rse a 25
million-dollar angel fund he also hosts
the askgaryvee show away providing as
much value as possible by taking
questions about social media
entrepreneurship startups and family
businesses and giving his answers based
on a lifetime of building successful
multi-million dollar companies the show
is available as a podcast on itunes
stitcher and SoundCloud he left out of
this vial that he's also written the
best-selling New York Times best selling
three books you should definitely check
out he's a prolific public speaker he's
giving keynotes at LeWeb South by you
should definitely watch his youtube
channel he was named to both Fortune and
cranes 40 under 14 consecutive years has
been profiled in New York Times Fortune
and Inc let's officially give a big
round of applause to Gary Vaynerchuk so
for those who haven't followed you I
think they really want to hear more from
you than me
for those who don't follow you can you
tell them a little bit about what you
are all about what drives you at your
core uh
what drives me at my core you know I was
born in the former Soviet Union so I'm
an immigrant so I think there's a couple
different things that drive me you know
starting from humble beginnings and and
gratitude I would say gratitude drives
me I'm very very very grateful and
thankful for the natural DNA skills that
I was gay
did for the fact that I think I'm a
hardcore entrepreneur that was born in a
communist country and was born at the
right time that allowed during depths of
the Cold War to get out of the Soviet
Union come to the US I'm driven by I'm
driven by paying back having two
tremendous parents though very very
different
giving me a pretty well-rounded
opportunity to be successful both by
instilling tremendous self esteem my mom
and by and by instilling you know truth
and honesty and work ethic my dad and
and so I'm I'm driven by the fact that I
very much am self-aware to know that I
have a lot of talents and things that I
was gifted with and I want to deliver
against that luck and when you meet
somebody at a party they've never heard
of Gary Vaynerchuk and they say hey man
what do you do what do you say
dominate you guys are fast friends you
know it's funny all I will say that
sometimes it's interesting to what use
that as a as a proxy to figure out what
the other person is about right yeah
some people like it some people hate
that I tell them um you know I wish my
wife Lizzy was here she laughs every
time this comes up because obviously I
do a lot of things I'm very
entrepreneurial that way I I tell them
that I'm a businessman or an
entrepreneur or or whatever really comes
you know whatever I'm in the mood for
sometimes I tell them I'm a die-hard
Jets fan you know like whatever's
whatever is uh whatever's whatever's the
moment but at the end of the day I'm
always very interested in thrilled to
talk about myself so as much room as
they give me to talk I'll fill them in
on the whole goddamn narrative if they
allow me to so what do you tell people
who who know you well right when when
they're asking you what you're working
on what are things that you know for
people who follow you a lot right what's
your day-to-day look like what are you
working on that what do you focus most
of your time on I mean I would say that
I'm primarily the CEO vaynermedia you
know the company's gone from 30 to 550
people in the last four years that's a
lot of that's a lot of stuff you said
CEO not see all right CEO
uh I would say that more and more I'm
raising a very large round for my next
fund so I think I'm gonna be spending
more and more time on the Investor front
how much is a large round definitely you
know north of 150 million so I'll I'll
be getting more into a and B round
dynamics than just angel investing i I
I'm spending a lot of time you know as a
lot of you know lately on my personal
brand the the askgaryvee show has really
reconnected me with my audience at a
level that over the last two years has
been a little bit more stagnant because
I've been so head down as the CEO of the
company and operating and so once I felt
fulfilled it's funny for a lot of you
that do know me that era of 2009 to 11
where I kind of emerged as a figure in
the web 2.0 movement I I didn't want to
be categorized as you know the narrative
first was hey there's this young kid who
built his family business and that's
worth paying attention to and then kind
of my personality and my speaking and my
content took over the narrative and for
myself selfishly I wanted to remind
myself that I was a business man and so
running Vayner and growing it and now
having my second rodeo of big Bill's in
this building feels fulfilling and I
think as soon as I kind of felt
fulfilled then I was well on my way to
doing that I kind of went back into
engaging at a higher level but I figured
out something that was more scalable
which is how the show the show got uh
got created actually I meant to have you
introduce us as the NJ tech meetups can
you give us an official welcome you
won't do it I don't force it has to come
naturally we'll get there we'll get
there
so a few interesting things in there one
is you said that uh you know you emerge
as this web 2.0 personality but was it
by mistake well I mean you know was it
by mistake I were you sitting at home
thinking you know what I could
capitalize on this I could build a brand
and I see the future of my brand and how
it's gonna affect my businesses or was
it holy [ __ ] I got 50,000 views today on
something of what happened it was that I
thought YouTube was gonna be a very big
deal and I went all in on it in 2006
when you know most of the world didn't
know about it and then I started
realizing there was this tech community
like I wasn't even though I had an econ
site
it's 96 I was in Jersey I wasn't really
thinking about what was going on in
Silicon Valley and so I could tell that
this was the very different internet
emerging from what I grew up with in the
late 90s and I thought it was going to
be a pretty big deal and I kind of was
at a place in my career at 30 years old
recognizing man a lot of things that I
think are gonna happen happen and it's
cool that I can build a much bigger wine
business because of this but maybe
there's a bigger and better and quicker
path to owning the Jets and this angel
investing thing is interesting and and
and I just started having a really
interesting time with myself a decade
ago of like hey there's something else
here that I might be able to use in a
different way than just selling a couple
more cases of Pinot Noir and that became
the process and then and then Twitter
came out I jumped on it I invested in it
I used it the leaderboard came out
people cared about it I was in the top
50 people that were followed everybody
else was a tech TV personality Leo
Laporte I just seen Kevin Rose it was
very tech it wasn't mainstream and then
there was this wine person on it so a
lot of people gravitated towards me
being crossover I was in Jersey I was
doing a wine show on YouTube I was
different
and then I was I was just intrigued by
this tech thing that uh this was clearly
going to evolve it'd be a bigger part of
our world and so I just went all-in
so you mentioned something there about
wanted to be a business man and so do
you feel like starting a digital focused
company maybe you think of Wine Library
TV is that or Wine Library ask this kind
of business but but are do you feel like
vaynermedia has validated what you were
really after or were you just as proud
of what you accomplished with Wine
Library I'm equally as proud I just
needed to remind myself that I was a
businessman and not a talking head were
you having doubts there because the
business went well it seems oh it seems
I wasn't having doubts I just uh I just
uh didn't like the narrative that was
being painted and I needed it for as
much of outwardly optically for the
market I don't want to be compared to
people that I feel don't build
businesses I'm flabbergasted by people
buying people's business books of people
that have never built
[ __ ] business and I wanted to remind
the market myself the game that I was a
businesslike builder I wanted to go into
Madison Avenue world where everybody's
like Oh Twitter boys coming and I wanted
to show them what I have showed them
which is I'm a much better [ __ ]
businessman than you and I'm gonna build
the biggest best agency of all time in
your [ __ ] mouth tell us how you
really feel so that's you know I'm I'm
very driven by the climb right I think
being an immigrant I guess or just
having this DNA I don't like winning I
like losing being a Jets fans good for
me you know like like my quarterback
getting punched in the mouth and
bringing his jaw that feels good to me I
like the struggle I like the struggle
and so I I i always think that a true
entrepreneur loves the process more than
the riches I don't give a [ __ ] about the
stuff that comes along I want it it's
nice it's nice to have money it's great
but the game the game is my drug like
there will never be a game over for me
there's no dollar amount that the game
the process the climb the that is the
drug that drives me that is my oxygen
competing is my oxygen and business
unlike being an athlete is the whole
time you know I've become friendly with
a lot of athletes in the last half
decade especially and at 32 33 35 38
you're like finished you're like
reinventing yourself like everything
you've ever known
you know I turned 40 in November and I
feel like I'm just now getting into ok
these next 20 years that's the prime of
being a business so that's what I love
and so I needed another challenge I had
one in the wine business I had
established a personal brand of sorts
but I needed to go into a new game where
I was starting from a zero place and I
believe that that will be the narrative
I truly believe that will be my
long-term narrative that I will go into
two to three more spaces in my career
maybe four where even though I will have
more wealth and more things it will be
disproportionately stacked against me
because climbing and
proving people listen I love the I told
you so I do and I know that that's not
Noble I recognize that that's not like a
thing people like to say I just don't
want to lie to you I love it
nothing makes me happier than to stick
it to you I've never said that I just
liked it and so hold on a second because
you talk about how many people here like
to say I told you so
lots it's good right it's not the worst
lies my thought but you talk about not
starting a business where you don't have
unique differentiated value but you just
said now you'd like to go in with you
know zero game so where's the balance
they're like what's really the video I
think that's a good call out cuz I do
think in general especially for the
people that most know me very much think
that my my the things that are going on
with me you have a lot to do with the
fact that I believe I'm a contradiction
and I'm a paradox and like I'm pulling
from very opposite directions right like
I truly truly truly like to my core
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody in this
room thinks about me while I while I
equally equally equally care very much
what you all think about me and it's a
very strange kind of pushing pull right
I want I went into I went into the
agency world where I didn't have any
advantages and did it yet I went in
there with all the advantages because I
was disproportionately knowledgeable and
social which I knew was gonna become the
advertising industry so you know pulling
from opposite directions a little bit
who's the last guy who said that you
bothered them they really bothered you
who's the last person that was like I
don't like your stuff man you will be
much I mean there's people that say they
don't like me every day you're saying
you know in the paradox right you you
want to be light but you don't give a
[ __ ] but who's somebody who's who's
bothered you when you said man I really
wish that you know maybe a celebrity or
so everybody like no nobody likes you
like like random like like Joey McGee 49
leaving a one-star review on Amazon on
Jab Jab Jab right hook I'm devastated
like to meet to me it's not to me it's
not a ya know to me it's everybody right
it's they're all equal like from LeBron
to lachemann like it doesn't matter to
me it's just a human that I have not
communicated in a way that
been consumable or interesting to them
and I'm and I'm fascinated by that and I
think about those things so on the fund
you said you're raising a maybe 150
million dollar fund or more yeah you
know 25 is a good start but that takes a
lot of focus yes how much of your time
do you spend investing versus now yeah
in the last fund uh well you know Phil
Toronto who kind of was my assistant and
and grew up with me and is very much my
investing right-hand man have scaled
that AJ was involved he's helped scale
that so I'm an intuitive investor anyway
so I don't need a whole lot of data the
new one I will and I've brought in
senior partners and infrastructure from
very large funds and so they'll be more
rigor and and clearly there'll be things
that I have to give up I'm speaking a
lot less you know I'm chopping off
things spec meetings you know I'm trying
to chop out time because I'm gonna need
a lot more time to deploy against the
fund behavior which is gonna have a
standard three hour meeting each week
which is crazy in my world so you know
I'm definitely um I'm definitely heading
towards a direction where it's gonna be
taking more of my time I think there's a
lot of people here and many watching who
think if if vayner/rse are you as an
angel invest in their company they're
hanging out with you and you're like
spending hours with them a week what
tell people what the reality is of when
they get if they get a check from you
what that looks like
well this is interesting my prior
behavior was it was all bat phone like
there was no hanging out unless you
needed me and and and highest use of
time right like just now button a great
startup that were involved in I
literally while I was sitting here and
getting ready they're trying to close an
engineer and so I emailed the engineer
and said it would really matter to us if
you join the team and he just replied to
me as like holy [ __ ] Gary Vee I'll join
that's good so so there's times when I
can do that but what I want to do with
this next fund so 25 million dollar
vayner/rse 93 investments next fund 150
to 250 million dollars 10 to 20
investments so what I want to do is go
all-in and go in in a series a or series
B use vaynermedia use myself to
disproportion affect the outcome and so
the behavior of an investment for me is
going to change quite a bit
it's
less early-stage clearly but it's going
to it's going to allow me to actually
impact the result more than more than
I've been able to in the past so will
there be a seed stage fund maintained or
you're thinking it's something I'm still
debating and the last two weeks of
August or the last week of August first
week of September I'm going to go away
and spend time with the family and
clearly in the downtime I think that's
probably the biggest thing I'm figuring
out if I get a vote we need you in the
seed space yeah I mean I mean I don't
think you know I think you know I can't
leave the seed space it's a place that
I'm strong in it's how do I do it what
do I do it do I do I team up with people
do I do it personal carved out like I
don't know I'm not gonna go I'm not
gonna not meet with people who've got
seed investment opportunities I just
need to figure out what's right for me
and what's right for them so one of the
things that I was in e ir at DFJ Gotham
a venture capital firm in the city and I
learned a lot about the venture space
there one of them was I prefer operating
companies then investing in them some
curious if you've had any aha moments in
running the fund that of change your
perspective on you know you haven't
raised gamble for your businesses and so
I'm curious what you think of it being
on that side of the table I think it
speaks to what my next behavior is gonna
be I want to be more involved you know
just betting on horses and jockeys is
interesting I've made a shitload of
money doing it but it's not as
interesting as having a disproportional
impact on the outcome there's nothing
bigger than running your own [ __ ]
but if I'm gonna write somebody a
fifteen million dollar check I'm gonna
be in there you know and so I want to
help and you know now I have an engine
right vaynermedia is a true engine it
disproportionally is helping the things
I'm involved with it's nice to get paid
you know 150,000 a month in fee it's a
hell of a lot better to make a fifteen
million dollar investment go 6x so you
caught me off guard there but when so
when you and I've you know I've met at a
at a conference where I saw you speaking
at corporate event Chicago in Chicago
you can't well done I often wear bright
pants tonight I kind of toned it down
but I make sure that when I'm near Gary
I stand out I had the big bright blues
on that day so I noticed you know that's
a corporate card you talk a
lot about speaking to your audience you
know being where your audience lives and
you were in front of the audience it was
awesome but you're dropping lots of
f-bombs and I'm very curious I feel like
this is a very deliberate strategy of
yours
so one is why do you choose to do that
in a space where you know that the
corporate cultures tend to disagree with
it and two is why are they why is it
censored on the askgaryvee show my am i
catching that right it's two things so
one it's actually stunningly not
deliberate
I'm actually not capable of controlling
my DNA I really listen here's a good
example I probably am leaving more than
seven figures a year on the table
because I curse in public that's real
money
that's Bank right like real money I'm
I'm just not capable like the more
they're like this size like it gets me
going and I get very Jersey doubt and I
grew up very into you know Eddie Murphy
and Richard Pryor and I get a little bit
of that flavor go right around the
rascals go weren't you what's that
rascal yeah
so like I just get excited on stage I
curse I can't help it I'd rather not
curse in a corporate environment because
I know that there's other people in the
audience that would then book me if I
didn't
the only now the askgaryvee show
censoring on youtube i don't think it's
censored the reason it's censored on
facebook is because we're running ads
against it and if you can't run ads if
it the curse thing is going on and so
that's the only reason when you want do
you watch the back no you go so you've
never seen it do you feel like it's
laughing like I can't watch yeah I would
never
I can't watch myself what happens when
you want you are you bothered by it like
do you feel like oh man I should have
said this you've really trimmed down you
look good no I just don't watch like I
don't I'm like time to watch something I
know what I [ __ ] said if I remember
that I [ __ ] met you in Chicago I know
what the [ __ ] I said an hour ago
I'll give you that
well how my real question there's let's
take that watching it back how critical
are you of yourself not at all
yeah so what's the last thing you [ __ ]
up that you should have done differently
I have no idea
yeah you haven't thought back about
something went wrong nope
all right next question there's a lot of
I'll expand cuz that was funny but like
I'll expand like probably like oh my god
I couldn't even begin to think about
first of all the all the things that
I've done wrong have a lot to do with
the things that I didn't do right like
I'm happy I miss I promise you you can
only be tied with me right this second
in happiness in life you can only be
tied so how in the world could I
possibly look back right whatever the
mistakes I made like not doing the vodka
with Usher that might have been a
mistake
right like like you know not doing a TV
show on Bravo may be a mistake right
passing twice on uber 'he's angel round
definitely a mistake you know you know
not taking that flight to San Francisco
to get into Pinterest that'll add a
hundred million dollar valuation when I
knew it was gonna pop and just making
some dumb decision I mean I've made so
many mistakes but when my net score is
at this moment the way I feel in my
stomach which is pure and utter
happiness and gratitude and feel awesome
and everything's great then I I can't
waste time worrying about what I didn't
do because what I've done has been more
than fine so there's a lot of people in
the audience there you look that's a
good one
do I think maybe won't admit it but
think that money will open up the doors
of AB Yunus I probably I can definitely
relate to this and money's not bad right
like like this is an interesting thing
that I'm trying to figure out like the
cliche thing to say is no look there's
been some really interesting studies
about this $75,000 range I actually
believe it like it's stunning like like
it just I actually think the money
argument is very similar to like giving
relationship advice I do not give
relationship advice like because that's
insane
every relationship has its own context
right like what works for me and
Lizzie's not gonna work like it's just
different the way me my dad role it's
not like scalable for others like
everybody does their own thing right
everybody does their own thing
same thing with money I know people that
like you know made a hundred thousand
like a year in their life
and that was it they made it and they
loved it and like life is phenomenal and
then I know people that make fourteen
million dollars a year then like anymore
like when I get there I'll get there you
know like I think it's a very personal
thing it's predicated on how you're
wired and what you value in life the
ultimate thing that I value is being
able to do what I want to do at all
times which takes money in a certain way
for sure so that's me next is to play
the game that I've played since I was
six which is selling [ __ ] right after
that I'm good right and from from a
selfish standpoint
everything else is family centric so I
think a lot of people here are
stunningly happy by the market's point
of view on this with a relative low or
relative high money amount it's just
personal so and tell people who don't
know about a little about your baseball
card background and maybe you know what
you've learned from that that you buy
today yeah I mean I was 12 and I was
making $3,000 a weekend selling baseball
cards in the malls of New Jersey and my
teachers told me I was a loser because I
was getting D's and F's and I was making
more money than them on six weekends and
so I couldn't believe them and it made
me realize I was doing something
different than what the market had
accepted and it's been the narrative of
my whole life I've been marketing and
playing and doing differently than what
the current market feels is right of the
moment and then it shows up and hangs
out with me that is my narrative back to
the happiness piece what are the what
defines happiness for you first and
foremost with no [ __ ] clothes second
is the continuous health and well-being
of the twelve or thirteen people that
mattered most to me in my life to me I
am crippled and I am scared shitless of
the and I think about it multiple times
a week multiple times a week I will be
in the moment of whatever I'm doing and
I will stop and I will think whoa
I could literally get a phone call right
now and somebody could tell me that
somebody I love is dead or really sick
like whoa like this is a weird thing and
I'm kind of breaking it down for you
this is like I don't know how you guys
roll but this is real multiple times I'm
talking 5 to 15 times a week I will be
in my life and I will
it's almost like I'm preparing myself
for it right I will recognize that
everything that all this happiness that
I just spewed on you is gone in us I'm
actually very curious if my going away
is predicated on my first real
substantial struggle with a health
situation or something really bad have I
mean I will check the [ __ ] out there
will be no like using social media to
console me I will go into a cocoon I
know myself I was and that's just where
so well you know that's it like that to
me like the continued like this minute
that that hasn't happened yet I'm good
you know that pumped like and so that's
and really everything else is kind of
gonna be good fine have you noticed that
as you've aged that's been more under
well actually I've gotten better imagine
how weird I was like when I was 12 I
used to have this nightmare that my
family decided to go back to Russia for
a family reunion and the plane crashed
in Siberia and for some [ __ ] reason I
always survived with random different
family members in the reoccurring dream
I mean I once prayed on my porch for two
hours because I thought my mom died in a
car accident because I was watching my
brother and sister she went to the mall
she should have been back three hours
earlier but there was this huge car
accident this was pre cellphones so took
her three hours to get home and
literally on the porch of my house I
prayed to God that my mom was alive so
I'm a little bit [ __ ] up like that
I promise you're not alone here yeah I'm
big on that like guy like I really wish
people had real perspective I my dad
doesn't have it that great to be honest
and sometimes I tell him that I wish
like one time at the height of an
argument around perspective I said you
know what dad I wish I [ __ ] died so
you know you would really understand
what to be upset about you know like
like I get really upset when kizhi in
the inter 12 circle
the most at the top but I really
struggle with people that complain I
really do
I really I really struggle with
complaining I like like many of you like
based on how well it's doing this Monday
morning video I made a couple months ago
where like I talk about like how lucky
you are to be a human being I really
believe that [ __ ] I really believe that
if you got practical for a minute and
wrap your head around that you actually
were able to become a human being that
that is the most insane [ __ ] thing of
all time it's so crazy
we are the kill we are the ultimate
species it's us right and then you live
in America [ __ ] you to complain about
anything like like like like you know
you could have you could have been like
a ladybug in Brazil that sucks so so
like wait am i ladybug I'm very I'm very
I'm very very very very very thankful
and pumped and like just don't
understand what people complain about
and honestly right now it's real bad
because right now the reason that's
really bad because things are really
good like I don't think people recognize
how good it really really is right now
and so like you know eventually there'll
be whether it's a terrorist attack or
Wall Street will [ __ ] up again or
whatever will happen like you know I I
recognize that there's you know in tech
it's good in certain practical parts but
all America different things it's not as
good but like it's good it's it's
[ __ ] good and so complaining while
it's good really sucks because there's
some so much worse out there
I mean I really hate this term but I'll
ask it anyway because I think it's it's
relevant do you think we are in a tech
bubble yes and no I think we're an
entrepeneur bubble I think there's a lot
of people sitting in this room that
think they're entrepreneurs and they're
not
entrepreneurs I just think there's a lot
of people that really don't understand
what it takes to be the end and what do
you think it takes a really heavy dosage
of fear and self-confidence pulling in
opposite directions and both and I think
a lot of people here have one or the
other and so I just don't you know when
when it's on you you know so right now
we have a lot of entrepreneurs who are
raising money and losing seems like a
learning experience they're not valuing
losing somebody else's money I think
that's dangerous and so I you know I'm
I'm I'm definitely romantic about this
I'm a pure bred entrepreneur I'm
watching a lot of students a lot of
operators a lot of great number 2 3 4 5
6 7 & eights thinking they're the number
one and that number want like the amount
of people who have startups right now
who don't work 15 and 18 hours a day
makes me laugh the amount of startups
friends that I have that are down the
Jersey Shore or at the Hamptons makes me
laugh they're soft I feel that really
soft are you seeing what do you thing
about you know people who come to you
with shitty ideas but they're great at
execution they how do you feel about
person vs. idea i'm i'm jacki / horse
yeah yeah i'm i'm person / idea on the
flip side i'm watching a lot of
youngsters who were hustling and working
18 hours a day they're stupid and and
I'm making that as a joke slang term for
like their product stinks they've got no
shot they haven't thought it through
they haven't been through a couple
rodeos but they've got a lot of other
pieces and I think that through much
look it scares me how much better I am
today than I was 15 years ago when I
thought I was the best right like it
scares me how valuable experience really
is it scares me it's a real thing
because it makes me mad at who I was 15
years ago
so yeah I just think we're at a very
interesting it's very attractive to be a
business man or woman entrepreneur
founder right now and honestly what I
don't like is it's very easy you just
say you are and that's not real so
you've talked a lot about
ego arrogance confidence and I'm well so
I actually have the definition here for
because you and your show you were
trying to figure it out with the yeah
indeed I don't know unfortunately
there's this thing called the internet
so heard about it arrogance of
superiority manifested in an overbearing
manner or a poor or in presumption that
presumptuous claims or assumptions
American confidence a feeling or belief
that you can do something well or
succeed at something 100% do you think
there's anything wrong with being you've
said and I think I quote I believe I'm
one of the greats
yes which I respect I get that I think
that when you say I'm pretty sure that
qualifies as in arrogant qualities so
here's what I think about the helm I
think that it's equally gonna be fun for
me to watch this exact video forty years
from now and say that I was wrong and I
know that I will say that I was wrong if
I don't pull it off and I think that's
what balances me off so as part of your
arrogance your own little trick to keep
you motivated but you say these things
thinking I better live up to this [ __ ]
maybe yeah I think I tricked my yes I do
think that I decided in sixth grade then
I was gonna buy the New York Jets as
something to aspire towards in a world
that I want to keep climbing it felt big
it felt like ooh that's a long game
that's a long climb and so yeah I think
there's I would say there's some
definite truth to that it seems like you
if that's your real end goal game why
bother with vaynermedia why not it seems
like you've got the brand you've got the
connections you to raise the capital you
could buy the Jets you can stop bunches
and quarterbacks faces wide wide why
didn't you go right there because I
think that I'm pretty self-aware for all
my other characteristics and I think
that the way that I buy the New York
Jets is by using vaynermedia the machine
to disproportionally create outcomes for
me in the future because I've created a
scalable family and infrastructure to my
one natural skill which is
disproportionate marketing capabilities
I skipped the question would in relevant
2 min ago but I want to hit it on the
let me explain what that goes in a
couple Gary what does that mean in a
couple of you and a couple of years I
will buy a brand or a company for two
hundred million dollars and then I will
use the machine to sell it for 1.9
billion dollars
scale its scale so search will laid-off
its employees very abruptly the other
day even with that I I saw the headline
yeah so basically female CEO correct
raised I forget the amount five to ten
million
she put a post out today of what
happened she did couldn't read it so go
ahead
so I'll then I'll tell you my
understanding the situation they had a
very high burn rate couldn't raise
enough capital had four hundred
full-time employees yeah and very very
abruptly in a company where they
preached transparency right Monday
morning people get in we're out of
business
yep fake entrepreneur yeah that's my
question what do you think about that
what do you get the right way to handle
situation like that is not that I mean I
don't want to speak to it cuz I don't
know what the hell I'm talking about but
that sounds bad do you think okay so
well let let's talk about the real issue
here you know that your cash burn the
you're always running out of money and
well it sounds like not an equal balance
of complete confidence and complete fear
seems like confidence took over and so I
know you have a big appreciation for
people who are upfront but you must use
respect so what do you think would have
been an appropriate time to give our
employees a heads up that no CEO didn't
know how to manage their business it
sounds like it should've happened six
months earlier where she or the rest of
her team or maybe the CFO I don't know
the details sure so though though if
she's the CEO it's her fault
like that's what I mean by being a
number one so it's her fault and it
sounds like she didn't know how to
manage the burn and sounds like she
should have done cuts six months ago and
maybe you know here's the thing
I am confident because I know I can get
really unfair quick and and you have to
understand what that means the reason
that company went out of business if it
sounds like the way it went out is maybe
she didn't want to go to a co-working
space instead of the office they had
maybe she you know didn't want to you
know believe it maybe she wanted to
continue to fly you know more
comfortably than two connecting flights
like these are the things I believe like
you control your bird I'm very proud
that vaynermedia and Wine Library
completely self-funded no cash and
to the business Steve Ross bought a
piece of vaynermedia but that went
directly into mine in a J's pockets not
a penny into the business the business
runs on its own cash flow and I was very
excited about AJ graduating and building
a business that had a PML instead of
raising ten million dollars raising
money is a really bad way to learn on
how to build a business it's really bad
it's not real when do you think people
should raise money well look I think I
think on the flip side raising money's
great I just know that a lot of people
aren't good enough to handle it I do
think that raising money smarter when
you have leverage so after you've
scrapped it and you made it happen you
have leverage money will come to you on
your terms versus you going out and
getting it and so I just believe in
leverage one of the biggest reasons I
like to pay forward put out content
engage do this tonight is I want the
leverage of providing value first I
always say whoever asks first is losing
and so I love providing value that way
and so it sounds like a story of clear
mismanagement what did she say in her
blog post that she felt really badly
she's been very upset that the reality
was they thought maybe they had a
somebody coming in last minute it didn't
happen you know it's tough I mean it's
tough yeah so there's probably a lot of
people the audience who have a very
small social following and they see your
success with social and they're
wondering how they attack social like
well you're like Ramon's wife has 100
followers on Instagram which is also
something what does she do to get to a
thousand to get that 5,000 to get to
10,000 has she earned what's taking her
shoes off she'll get more fun got some
pretty toes girl well there's something
there's something that there's something
that I think people don't understand
about this game which is talent matters
like saying stuff that's interesting or
creating content that's valuable whether
in entertainment form or information
form or utility form is not something
everybody just is naturally born with
you don't you know just cuz you get an
on Instagram or a periscope or meerkat
or two
or Facebook just cuz you get on it
doesn't entitle you to anything and so I
think the best way to build a following
is to provide value whatever that may be
and value can be defined in a lot of
ways for me I had already I have
business things to say I'm I have
experience and you know disproportionate
leverage and understanding of what's
happening in the marketplace because I'm
living it so I have something to say it
brings people value you know a nice
young lady just came up to me and said I
gave some advice at Columbia are you
still here thank you like she was at
Columbia I remember that
d-roc you were is that where is that
where you like when I first met you -
and who else was there that day Alex
DISA mom it was a very special thing I
did that night was really special I've
heard like ten good stories from
Columbia small group 4050 people she
came up to me she goes you gave me some
advice at that event I used it it's been
good for my life you know when you can
do that people will continue to come and
listen to what you say so I think the
best way to build a following is to
provide value and there's a lot of ways
to provide value maybe you can't come up
with original content like I do maybe
you need to be in the DJing business
maybe you have a good eye of what is
good content and you're repurposing it
and passing it on that's very valuable
very curation is outrageously valuable I
see a lot of people who are naturally
good at curation trying to be original
writes a lot of DJ's trying to be
songwriters a lot of songwriters trying
to be DJ's right I think you need to
find what you're good at but please
understand you're not entitled to a
single [ __ ] follower and if you have a
hundred people following you on
Instagram
that's insane a hundred people want to
know what you're putting out to the
world that's unbelievable
so I hate when people are crying like I
have a small following I'm like you're
not entitled to any following do you use
tools no I don't I just when you're
feeling that you put it out you don't
test times you don't you test stuff you
just know and and we've started now that
I have a team with the show and
everything there's some better thinking
but it's still pretty [ __ ] organic
what's the mission you you you produce
first of all how many askgaryvee shows
do you produce at a time is it one and
done or you want at that time one
Dirac we've never India we've never
taped to in one day I even get mad when
d-roc wants to put it up the next
morning I think contextual matters I
think the day it happened it goes out is
hugely important I'm scared that I say
something and that the next day I mean
look what happened to face of my
facebook I think Facebook's gonna be a
competitor meerkat and periscope and it
came out like a day later like if we
were holding on to that I would have
been weird
so no people
I don't change shirts
what so tell me what that promotional
machine looks like as you hit everything
so you record I'm in complete control of
my Instagram and Facebook we the team
schedules the I'm in control I'm sorry
of my Twitter and Instagram the team
schedules the posts for Facebook but
India's here who does a lot of my copy
like I'm texting with her titles like
I'm very scared for it you know I want
India to work with me forever especially
India because I love her so much but if
India was if India we talked about Rams
applause we gotta hit it up for her I've
always been very self-aware of like back
to authenticity that if if I was faking
this me doing [ __ ] and that if India and
I had a spat and she no longer worked
she would have enormous ammo to say like
this guy's full of [ __ ] I didn't like
I'm scared of that
wait are you full of [ __ ] oh sudden no
that's what I'm saying I'm saying the
reason I do all my stuff is cuz I don't
want that like you know how pumped
people get when a celebrity replies to
them do you know devastated they get
when they find out it was the assistant
like you know like I don't want to lose
equity that's why I love all the
live-streaming and when Twitter video
came out as a lot of you know I started
replying and that like it was a good way
for me to prove like I do my [ __ ] so
Instagram and Twitter is all me face it
my facebook fanpage we use a little bit
more like publishing but obviously when
I'm replying in it it's always me so
that's what's going on so you've
mentioned a lot about India interviews
me our medium posts are longer form
stuff is transcribed from answers from
the show and then if it needs to get
filled out she'll interview me and that
becomes the post
I'm sure loud people say that you think
of where the help you find a time for
all this
I find a time because I find incredibly
passionate d-roc Emily you know Zach
where's Zach Zach right there who
designs all the [ __ ] beautiful [ __ ]
you see who's like fastest [ __ ] not like
a normal [ __ ] designer you know like
like I find I find I find people that
are passionate and and I find people
that are do like indie and I are very
different
Emily and I are very similar right we're
both really good cheerleaders and rah
rah and pumped
d-roc and I have a ton of similarities
but like I just I'd build teams I build
teams so if you're okay this is an
important point right if you are just
starting out you're one person you're
two people maybe you're three and you
know how valuable content is but you're
trying to fundraise you're trying to
build a product you're trying to mark
your I was running a 100 person 60
million dollar business I had no [ __ ]
d-roc I had no team from 2006 to 2014
and I did all my [ __ ] content but you
you discipline so so stop watching
[ __ ] entire seasons of [ __ ] you
know house of cards
and a lot of you've heard this let me
this is a good chance to clarify Andy
Rock make sure you edit this part here's
my thing on stop watching lost or house
of cards you know stop complaining
people always here's my thing if you're
pumped with your life and you're good
and you're not complaining
do you like don't work at all I don't
give a [ __ ] it's this message is for the
people like oh I don't have time
like what was me like why am I not as
big as you I don't have money I don't
it's bad like I didn't get a check if
you're complaining you better self audit
yourself because if you're complaining
and I audit you I promise you I promise
you I will find four [ __ ] hours that
you're not doing jack [ __ ] you're
sleeping and by the way I'm a fan of
sleep sleep is important
so let's but but you might be sleeping
eight hours and sevens cool too
that's one right you're [ __ ] I don't
know like [ __ ] playing mobile games
[ __ ] you
I've never played one second of a mobile
game like literally like really like
you've got time for Angry Birds and
you're complaining get the [ __ ] out of
here so you know so so my big thing is
that my big thing is that I don't want
to hear that you're one person just
starting out and you don't have time for
content your actions my friends are much
much much louder than your words your
actions are your game when I'm 80 and
I'm not one of the greats I will look
into a camera be like I was wrong I had
a good run I did really nice but I'm not
one of the greats I'm solid I'm on that
next year maybe two tears down and so
that's the way it's gonna be
it doesn't matter what I say it's gonna
matter what happens
Frank who's sitting right there who did
the Wine Library billboards that you
might remember that's the man right
there he got to see me you know back in
the day and I don't remember he
hopefully he remembers a little bit
better than I do but like I'm sure I had
plenty bravado and was talking a ton of
[ __ ] back then too and guess what I've
done a lot more since then and if I keep
that momentum like that's the game right
like either you're right or you're wrong
either you win or you lose but if you're
gonna come to me and tell me you don't
have time in a world where I work every
[ __ ] second for 18 hours a day right
you're gonna have a tough time making me
feel bad that it's not happening for you
because that's part of it
like I love people that are like no no
no Gary I'm gonna work smart that's good
like I fully feel comfortable I'm
working [ __ ] smartest [ __ ] every
minute like putting in the work matters
like it just does like talent is
massively important but putting in the
work matters and it's fun for me to see
Sugar Ray and people this generate like
those gap guys stand up you guys I love
you guys you'd always come to my books
let's clap it up for these guys I want
you guys um I want well listen you
better [ __ ] take your help because I
need some more time and you're old so
get your [ __ ] together sugar right
yeah you have I appreciate it brother if
you think those guys from that
generation want to hear your [ __ ]
whining that you don't have time go [ __ ]
yourself
that's but but honestly I'm real serious
about this please please go talk to you
if you're lucky enough I'm not you know
I I don't I didn't grow up really with
Grand Prince except for one and now
she's sick and it's tough like go talk
to your grandparents and go ask them to
introduce you to four or five of their
friends and go ask them how they rolled
in life like what was tough when there
was war and [ __ ] depressions and real
[ __ ] and you're crying that you don't
have a thousand [ __ ] periscope
followers cut the [ __ ] out of here
series it is by the way I am convinced
by the complaining that's in the market
convinced that we are well on our way I
don't know where we are but we lost like
just so you guys know I want this on the
record I want to look back at this
America lost we lost it's like and by
the way it's not because like I love
America more than breathing it's because
we're just too far along and having our
run and you could just see it 9th place
trophies is that where we're at like
that's how we're gonna roll like we got
to be that politically correct with our
kids that if you come in 9th [ __ ]
place you won get the [ __ ] out of here
this is why there's so many fake
entrepreneurs you know why that and I
don't know this gal and I'm fair for me
to use that proxy I promise you if I
audit that gal she was fake winning fake
winning is really hurting us so if you
want to win if you want to do your thing
if you you have to understand the market
the market it doesn't care it doesn't
care if you went to Harvard it doesn't
care if you grew up in the [ __ ]
boogie down bronx with a welfare mom
it's gonna be the market and you've got
to win in it period and that's it the
market always rules and way too many
people here don't understand that they
celebrate when they raise money we are
in a culture right now where we
celebrate people when they raise debt
it's broken my friends and shit's gonna
hit the fan I'm gonna play this [ __ ]
video in four years when it does and say
now what
now we're gonna see who's a wartime
general right now we've got peacetime
generals real easy be a 26-year old
entrepreneur right now where you can
just raise money cuz the [ __ ] dentist
wants to find his Zuckerberg real easy
show me show me on the next bubble burst
who's gonna make money during that show
me so for you guys been coming here a
long time if that doesn't motivate you I
don't know what the hell will I have a
long list of a lot more questions that I
would love to get into but I promised
Gary we would let him out of here for a
very important meaning he's got I'm
gonna be five minutes late cuz I'm
feeling it right now you want to keep
going we could keep going how much fun
one is greater than zero that video was
the rant that I just said now right
which was if you watch that video that
Dirac did an incredible job editing and
telling the Great's Oh Stefan
good job d-roc way to not take credit
something I need to learn one is greater
than zero is basically the rant I just
gave right which is like you have to be
thankful for like you know it was
talking about how I get a lot of expose
it has to do with your pitch right which
is it blows my if not every single
person in this room doesn't that has a
startup doesn't hit you up they don't
understand one is greater than zero I
did every single interview every sick 14
views 19 views 23 views I still do it
I'm way way way way way quote-unquote
bigger than a lot of people who say no
to somebody's podcast cuz they got
nobody listening and I'm still doing it
because I'm winning twice I'm bringing
value to a human being that's gonna use
my name to build their thing which is
gonna bring them value that feels good
that's the right thing and two there's
14 people that are gonna watch and of
those 14 seven might not know who I am
right we're in New Jersey Tech event
right now we're in a New Jersey tech
event I grew up in Jersey I am probably
one of the more successful New Jersey
based tech entrepreneurs
period how many people by show of hands
had no idea who I was before tonight
raise your hand one is greater than zero
gotta keep putting in the work every day
I've been on every [ __ ] channel 47
times and plenty of people just raised
her hand one is better than zero got to
keep putting in the work putting in the
work putting work that man right there
he wants to win I'm watching from afar
he's not getting a lot of traction he's
getting frustrated just like I got
frustrated aha a year and a half into
wine Lambie TV but you keep crying
against you're always one video away on
Instagram that who knows sees puts it
like you're just one moment away every
time if I don't know if he has the
talent if you've got it that matters I
don't want it I hope everybody since if
you put in 18 hours a day every day of
your life and you suck [ __ ] you lost
that matters too and so you also have to
think about what are you good at just
cuz it's cool to be a start-up founder
now doesn't mean that's what you need to
become I built a very unsexy business to
your point in the height of where I was
and the game because I was self-aware
that that was gonna be an engine for me
over 10 20 30 years when it could have
been a lot sexier to raise 50 million
dollars and play with the 14 ideas I
have but I Know Who I am and you've
talked about this before
how do people figure out their greatest
strengths and what do they let go you
know what get to you my man's keep
standing uh you know I I did a good
India helped me with this will you put
out a really good post about this I'm a
big fan of the following asked one thing
I think I do well and at vaynermedia
is I make everybody feel safe and so
that's really important to me because
when you make people feel safe they
start telling you the truth right so if
you are able to go home right now if
you're struggling to figure out what
you're good at if you're able to take
the ten to 20 people that are closest to
you siblings wives husbands partners
friends the 10 to 20 people you consider
the closest to you in the world and if
you were able to talk to them and make
them feel safe
before you ask them the following
question if you made them emphatically
for 20 minutes and said look I need this
is the most important question I will
ever ask you in my life you need to tell
me the truth my intuition is
you're not gonna want to tell me the
truth but you have to understand I'm
okay with it I'm in the right mind space
for this I need the truth and then you
ask them what do they think you're good
at and bad at it's an it's an amazing
and obviously I put out that post it
really resonated I'm getting crazy
emails of people like having amazing
things happen to them I think the only
if you do not have self-awareness which
is what I do think I have and I think a
lot of people don't have it the only way
you can gain it is by getting other
people to give you the data points but
most people won't tell you the truth so
it's on you to create an environment a
very safe environment for somebody to
tell you the truth of what they truly
think you're good and bad at and then
gather that data a lot of people don't
want to recognize what they're good at
or don't want to accept that they're bad
at something it's like that whole
American Idol singing thing right like
some of people really believe they're
great at singing and they suck [ __ ]
right like they really believe it and so
I don't think people are honest with
themselves there's a lot of things I
wish I was but but I just don't lie to
myself and I think lying to yourself has
held back the far majority of this room
from bigger upside so as you may have
heard a big part of the culture of this
group is trying to give back so what
what's something that everybody could do
tonight or tomorrow morning to help you
out that's a really interesting question
um the truth is that's a really
uncomfortable question for me you know
for somebody who is more than
comfortable throwing right hooks and
going in for the ask I don't know that
doesn't feel like I really you know back
to the leverage of giving first there's
plenty people here that I've given to so
they can give back because I feel like
I've established that leverage but to
somebody who doesn't even know who I am
you know I can't ask for something I'll
take a hug get up here get up here I'll
take the hug and let's ask that man yeah
what's your question in the back while
she makes her way up here I'm all about
hugs
instead of though the ng took me to five
big round of applause here come on
this is her second event I know she's
gonna be coming back is that the one
right there in the middle yeah standing
yeah stand up let me speak up just a bit
I don't know I swear to God I don't my
god if I knew how to teach
self-awareness
I'd probably quit right now and do it
because that's how I buy the [ __ ]
Jets right like and I'm sure and I'm
sure a lot of people can raise their
hand and give their rationale to how you
do it it's pretty intense
like if you really settle in to really
thinking about this and like I think for
the 50 people that I know the best yeah
and I think about the four or five that
I've desperately through my entire life
have tried to help somebody who I I
appreciate I do think I'm outrageously
self-aware it's probably my superpower
right like I don't know how to instill
it other than creating safety and
honesty communication
I just keep pounding at these core
things I I really really really believe
the thing that's holding people back is
the romantic version of who they think
they want to be or who they think they
are versus who they actually are I mean
it is a big deal I I really truly back
to an earlier point you made I really
really really love myself a lot I really
do but I'm also but I because I love my
shortcomings like they're just me like
know everybody's got them you've all got
shortcomings and we've all got strengths
it's just there is no perfect right I
mean that's why I'm so enjoying all
these Tom Brady email leaks his perfect
is going away really fast while he's
complaining about his you know pool
covers so you know I think that uh I
think that there is no perfect and so I
don't know to be honest with you but I
do know that it starts with you being
open open to go
they're right I know that that's right I
know that I'm completely you need to you
can't just say it anyway people in here
that I know intimately say they're
hustlers and then I watch because I'm
curious and they're just not so you
can't just say you want to let go up
there because if you're gonna go there
you're gonna have to look a lot of [ __ ]
in the face that you're not gonna like I
had a struggle through all my 20s you
know I I had a meeting with my team the
other day that I struggled with an
intense way because I was giving
negative feedback it's so uncomfortable
for me you know I'm bad at it and what
did that mean in my 20s at Wine Library
meant I was full of [ __ ] it means I
couldn't tell you your face you sucked
and I figured out ways to get you out
right that was something I had liked in
an authentic world I had to realize holy
[ __ ] I'm full of [ __ ] because I'm not
good at negativity and I can't give you
real feedback and I've learned and I'm a
much better operator at vaynermedia in
giving that feedback I'm not even close
emily is a good example like i've been
able to give a real feedback along the
way something I would have never been
able to do and so you've got to open up
yourself to two looking things that you
everybody in here right now in a second
can think of something that they're not
good at that isn't Noble that they're a
bad person in in a second that they know
they haven't addressed yet with
themselves that's intriguing that's the
beginning of the process it's it's
interesting [ __ ] you got him around like
we I don't think we have time for these
but it's up to you man I'll keep coming
a little bit all right I'll let you pick
them can you find out how fast the
Google the the ways eta is dear awkward
in the eart somebody help me like do not
get crazy what's that I have to go
alright one more is it yeah well you
pick it don't tell me what to do in the
other why are you being so negative
do you want me to hang for five minutes
was that if you can but if you can you
you can just do like a line of high five
I will definitely do a line of high five
don't I let it matter what I'm gonna do
one question cuz there's no way I'm
gonna be able get out of here without it
I I know a lot of people want to take a
quick selfie in a high five high prom I
make this promise to this group I will
do something in early 2016
just for this group that you'll manage
where you try to like do some sort of
thing for an hour
I can high-five and hey like whatever
I'm missing right now I'll make but I
have to run the [ __ ] out of here we
could we could make the the picture
happen with everybody thank you ready
awesome let's ask to take the one
question what do you got alphabet right
surprised yes because I'm very I'm very
flattered first I don't even I'm not
completely sure what your reference
thinking but like I trust me my egos big
enough that if you think that they're
stealing stuff for me I'm very flattered
here's what I can tell you what here's
how I interpret it I just don't think
they want to run the search business
anymore the original founders and thence
gave them a way to kind of focus on some
of the other stuff but I appreciate that
I appreciate your support all the time
listen a really fast follow up or
anything about non dot-com domains cuz
they were ABC that XYZ yeah I'm very
intrigued by that space I'm I'm a big
fan of the following my last name is
Vaynerchuk I would not call that
awesomely branded right I would also say
I made a massive mistake when I signed
onto Twitter by creating the user named
Gary V with two silent E's I'm a very
big believer that you make the name that
the name doesn't matter right Google and
Facebook and snapchat didn't mean [ __ ]
to anybody in here until they made it
mean something and so I've never been a
big you need to own this name or this an
app because I think it's the execution
that makes the name not the name that
makes the execution so I will say this I
really appreciate all of you I may jump
on some live stream on the way home
right now if I don't get to answer your
question or I might answer some
questions on Twitter Jersey I love you
I'll see you later hold on hold on hold
on hold on
a second so first one the first thing is
sit down it'll be 30 seconds the first
thing is I know you have a high bar and
your greatness bar is you you think it's
got a long way to go but I want to tie
the behalf of this group and bad for
myself we think you're one of the great
so thank you very much for that the
second thing you didn't know what's
coming is that I teamed up with the
mayor who I think had to leave and
you've earned the second certificate of
mayoral recognition and excellence and
innovation and with that you can go
buddy thanks a lot
[Applause]